you know I used to oh man oh man I'm
getting crazy memories right now holy
[ __ ] I used to play with a
counter-strike team and it was like it
was three Canadians and two of them were
really well known um [ __ ] [ __ ] how am
i blanking on their names they were
Oprah they had the funniest names dude
one of them was star hunk that's a great
name dude was thatõs and like they were
old as [ __ ] compared to me I think I was
like 14 15 playing with them on a team
and they used to go by they had like a
Russian name for their team they've run
this team for forever and I remember
playing against them a bunch they're
real good and I always wanted to be on
their team and when I did it was like a
big accomplishment for me is like a
teenager but then I remember like
jumping and voice chat with them for the
first time they're old as hell like deep
Canadian like hey bud yeah what how do I
say your name a and like screaming with
them was like so like it could be the
most intense [ __ ] and star honk or just
be like yeah they got a three coming up
banana right now maybe toss an eighth or
something need pause I need a star hung
could you drop me a gun yeah I got I got
busted up a last round wow these guys
are good yes the most temperate yeah so
temperate yeah but then they had this
third homey Biggums dickham's this fool
[ __ ] with dig'em he he was the first
time I knew that Canadians could be
[ __ ] okay oh man is full bad
attitude okay shitty attitude nothing
could ever be his fault if he died why
the [ __ ] are you with me eh I'm out here
alone just what the [ __ ] and star hunk
Biggums come down he getting angry is
not gonna help the situation
so are they friends in real life do you
think they yeah they all knew each other
in real life yeah yeah at least are
Honka tato still got you hey dos was
like I think 30 okay Wow just I don't
know he's sound is what now 44 oh dude
if they ever heard this they like what
[ __ ] yeah yeah no way that's crazy yeah
they listen to our podcast doubt it what
if they do I mean it'd be sick if they
did I'd love to reconnect yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna build a Miss
connections for like Craigslist was just
old counter-strike players that's a good
idea
otherwise another team are played on
with this [ __ ] dude named gambit I've
never been condescended harder than that
guy that I think I brought this up
before a little bit like I was like I
was oh I got my internet taken away or
some [ __ ] like I was this is when I was
like like coming out of being a badass
kid okay so like I had just joined this
team and then my mom was like you are a
badass kid you don't get a computer yeah
like you're like a badass kid no I just
you know knucklehead like just being
stupid okay she wasn't like you're a
badass
no like you know just like mmm getting
[ __ ] caught up in stupid [ __ ] and so
she's just like thought okay well this
is the only way I could punish him so
she I remember like getting my computer
taken away and then like because I
wasn't playing as much like I just like
my skill started to slide a little bit I
stood mind you I'm like 14 15 this guy
mid-twenties like socal like OC bro he's
like yeah man you're just like you're
not cutting it
I was like bro I like I can't play that
much he's like yeah but full that's not
our problem
like whatever bro like do your homework
I was like oh excuse me
he was like do your homework for
whatever the [ __ ] just like don't we
just we can't deal with it like don't
bring that here and I got cut really
yeah it was like the cold yeah I was the
shittiest but like at the time I was
like [ __ ] this fool yeah I mean hey
that's what it takes man yeah he wanted
to have a great counter strike team yeah
and you just weren't cutting it
yeah and that's sometimes that's yeah
yeah you got laid off yeah I did get
laid off from the team yeah that's the
funniest [ __ ] about the whole like video
games cause violence I've said this
before I said again [ __ ] I was
working jobs for free our strike teams
were were jobs like you dealt with all
the same politics of
as middle manager yeah yeah what another
worse than that [ __ ] dude selvages hmm
what was your gamertag hmm okay you're
not gonna say no okay no I'm just gonna
guess whatever you guess I'll say it's
right yeah ambiguous man late again
hmm thought we were meeting up at 10
a.m.
looks like it's 10:15 so why don't we be
on time next time yeah oh yeah it was
like that yeah like sorry gambit got
tied up in something and I'm really
sorry won't happen again
yeah well that's not our [ __ ] problem
fool do your [ __ ] homework man we're
trying to build a great team here okay
and if you're not gonna be a team player
yeah then I don't think there's room for
you on this team so why don't we not be
late again
and then then always there was always
the like the the second-in-command
[ __ ] he was the middle manager okay
the the team leader always always had
his right-hand man as always his
favorite and it was like that fool he
could suck [ __ ] but he could do no wrong
okay you do know long [ __ ] like you'd
be like Pavo what the [ __ ] you baited me
and you'd be like no I didn't and then
gambit he didn't bait utiful no one told
you to push no you just said to push no
I didn't okay
next round my boss is a [ __ ] dick
I'm 14 going through these [ __ ]
emotions like meet up with your friends
yeah bar after yeah team leader such a
dick man he's always been on my ass all
[ __ ] day and he's just a hypocrite
he's a [ __ ] hypocrite
I would like come downstairs after
playing sometimes like just angry and my
dad would be like are you good and I'm
like you don't even know a kind of day
ahead at the office you don't even know
what the [ __ ] I'm dealing with dads like
gambit again yeah yes okay my dad
cracking beers yeah yeah drinking
smoking cigarette about it son man the
man is just something else
Oh such a [ __ ] suit yeah just suit
for what for what cuz he's been working
the job five years longer than me better
than him I want to take his job that's
what I'm gonna do that what take his
[ __ ] yeah yeah bro okay Counter Strike
team's taught me [ __ ] what what I got
that early glimpse of like a dead-end
job through filing an HR complain with
someone trash-talks you trying to form a
union I'm tired of being [ __ ]
condescended and [ __ ] talk during
practice it's [ __ ] ah the boss you
are not Union at unionizing oh we are
you're not there's only like six peoples
it's really easy guys
yeah no we we just we just chatted about
it were you before most decided were you
yes so you can go [ __ ] yourselves yeah
and now guess what practice starts at
10:15 the weirdest [ __ ] was I met this
dude in college and we got talking about
counter-strike and he told me what team
he played for and they were like a
really high-level team and I was like oh
what the [ __ ] like you're that guy and
he was like yeah dude me my bro this dad
the third and I was like wow that's
really cool and then I remembered a lot
of them got caught cheating so I was I
got at the game yeah oh I see you're a
hacker yeah okay he's oh yeah I see he's
a hacker yeah that's the that was the
that was the you know the steroids of of
gaming I don't think I ever had like
plan mates that were people that weren't
my friends maybe like I had it was
always like friends of friends yeah you
know it's like people like we play for
and I with yeah it's never like I never
really like made friends with someone
random through Call of Duty or Gears of
War but I remember I always used to see
the same people yeah like we always used
to like we'd play enough where we just
get put in rooms with the same pay the
same people and you recognize their
gamer tags I guess one kid his gamertag
was I hate Asians nice just straight-up
just all capital letters racist I hate
Asians just shamelessly racist Wow and
we would always play against him nice
and yeah he was good he was I don't know
I don't really remember
remember I don't think I remember I was
just like damn this has [ __ ] up Jesus
there was always like oh yeah there was
some bad there were some bad ones now
that I'm thinking yeah like before Xbox
had their like they had their safety
filter in their vanity filter but people
would like figure out how to game it
yeah that's bad yeah that is bad ones
this is the gamer universe it attracts
[ __ ] like that yeah it's actually
kind of crazy the experience I had with
[ __ ] gaming cuz like and in a way it
was good because it pulled me out of
like some of the stupid [ __ ] that me and
my friends would like get into at the
time I got told you like I'm [ __ ]
like one of my boys I was like eh like
put me on like I want to deal like just
like trucks [ __ ] cuz I wanted to make
money okay and like I saw like the kind
of cash he was making I was like I want
that and he was like you want sleighing
I was like yeah and then he was like
starting to put me on but then like
gaming was easier and more fun mhm
and then when more fun than drug dealing
really yeah yeah surprisingly yeah how
crazy yeah and then like sort of you
know some kid I knew who got robbed like
some time within when I was like
thinking about doing it and I was like I
started thinking through the logistics
I'm like oh yeah I guess I'm like I'm
pretty easy to steal from you maybe not
a good idea
hmm but gaming was like for me it was
legitimately like finding a job like
you'd go on IRC and you try to find a
team and then like you have a tryout
which was like an interview and then
like it was so weird like thinking about
that I did that like for like and then
just got deeper and deeper into it I got
a dope the way that that is like you
know way teaching you the corporate
world before your oh yeah no and at the
age to consider what that would mean it
definitely did cuz like when it came
time to like get a job and [ __ ]
I honestly felt like because I had
actually been through that before like
interviews and stuff didn't scare me
yeah cuz like that that was the same
[ __ ] it's funny you're like parents are
gonna work every day and you're like I
wonder what the [ __ ] they do and then
you go and just do the exact same thing
on your computer honestly so it's just
funny to see these old [ __ ] boomers
be like gaming is [ __ ] terrible like
no gaming taught me how to get a job
actually Tom how to deal with people
yeah I think that's also the funny thing
I think back on is I always feel like
these people were
age they were always way older than me
mm-hmm talking [ __ ] to me being [ __ ]
to me and I would take it really
personal but like you know like stiff
upper lip like I just wouldn't react and
and all that and I'm like why why they
only my Oh cuz I'm the [ __ ] kid on
the team yeah I'm thinking [ __ ] baby
shut the [ __ ] off dude your [ __ ]
mouth bro used to game with this dude in
Atlanta
there's Jada who's the best yeah yeah he
was good at the game or he just was the
best dude I just bet he was his a homie
he like didn't take [ __ ] seriously [ __ ]
miss Jade I do miss Jada Jada a few and
somehow I hear this man get at me bro I
remember like we had played games and
stuff and then when I hadn't seen talked
to him in a while I started making music
and then my music was trash and he was
going a bro like like you know you'd be
like nah you you clever man you'd like
write punchlines man like you know you
got it that it uh then I remember we
like last time I talked to him I think I
was like maybe 1819 and we were like
getting caught up on music and stuff and
it was just like he was like ah bro I
knew you find it I told him I listened
like Shawn price and stuff and all that
he's like oh [ __ ] my man don't grow up
he's like this like older black dude
living in Atlanta and now honestly is
probably like in his mid-thirties like
with kids and [ __ ] but yeah memories bro
damn gaming shoutout Jada yeah and so
[ __ ] the [ __ ] media dude false
narrative about gaming
[Music]